In this brief segment,
we will discuss
an important application
of the convolution formula.
Suppose that X is a normal
random variable with a given
mean and variance.
So that the PDF of
X takes this form.
And similarly, Y is normal
with a given mean and variance.
So its PDF takes this form.
We assume that X and
Y are independent.
And we're interested in the
sum of the two random variables
X and Y. And we wish
to derive the PDF of Z.
Of course, the PDF of Z is given
by the convolution formula.
And now we plug in here, the
form for the density of X.
And here, we plug the
form of the density of Y.
Except that instead
of the argument Y,
we need to put in the
argument z minus x.
So we obtain this
form, where here we
have a z minus x instead of y.
Now this is an integral that
looks pretty complicated.
But it is not too hard to do.
One just needs to be patient,
rearrange terms, collect terms.
And the details of
the calculations
are not as interesting.
So we will skip them for now.
And I will just tell you
that the final answer
takes this form.
What is this form?
Well, it's
exponential of minus z
minus something squared
divided by a constant.
And we recognize
that this is the form
of a normal random variable.
It's a normal random
variable whose mean
is given by this term
here, it's mu x plus mu y.
And the variance of that
normal random variable
is that constant that appears
next to the factor of 2
in the denominator.
So the sum of these two
normal random variables,
these two independent
is also normal.
The fact that this
is the mean and this
is the variance of the sum,
of course, is not a surprise.
What is important in this
result that we have here
is that the sum is
actually normal.
Now, we carried
out this argument
for the case of the sum of
two normal random variables.
But suppose that we
had the sum of three
independent normal
random variables,
what can we say about it?
By the result that we just
discussed, this sum is normal.
This is assumed to be normal.
We assume that X, Y,
and W are independent.
Therefore, this sum
is independent from W.
So we're dealing
with the sum of two
independent normal
random variables again.
So this sum here is going
to be normal as well.
And we continue this
argument by induction,
and conclude that
more generally,
the sum of any finite number
of independent normal random
variables is normal.
This is a very important,
but also useful fact.
It means that when
we start working
with normal random
variables, very often
we stay within the realm
of normal random variables.
We can form linear
functions of them,
take linear
combinations of them,
and still remain in the world
of normal random variables.